بالموافقه التركيه تاتي في قطار عدد
متغيرات متغير الاول يتعلق بسعي تركيا
لاصلاح علاقتها مع الاوروبيه خاصه بعد
التوتر السنوات الماضيه ما يمكن لتركيا ان
تفاوض الاوروبيين على رجمه اتفاقات تبدا
من موضوع النزاع مع اليونان قضايا قبرص
التركيه مساله اللاجئين التي يمكن للتركيا
ان تعيد التفاوض مع الاوروبيين على منحها
مساعدات من اجل التعامل معهم استخدام
مساله النظام السويد لنيتو في مكاسب ما
يمكن للاتراك ان يفوضوا على تسهيلات
تجاريه مع اوروبا وتسهيلات لتاشيرات
الدخول للاوروبا للاتراك الى اوروبا تبدو
تركيا في موقع يتيح لها تحصيل بعض الشروط
بعد انضمام السويد مكاسب المكسب الاول
متعلق اسراع في اتمام صفقه طائرات المق
بالتاكيد على الالتزام السويد بمجاف
الاتفاق الثلاثي الذي وقع في مدريد خلال
قمه النيتو العام الماضي ما بين تركيا
والسهول احياء والمفاوضات انضمام تركيا
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتحسين صوره تركيا ربما
تحصل تركيا على رفع حظر كندي لبيع الاسلحه
وعدد من المنتجات الاخرى هذا الاوروبي ليس
بصدد ضم تركيا اليه في السابق كان الامر
معقدا والان اصبح اكثر تعقيدا مع صعود
تيارات اليمين المتطرف ووصولها الى السلطه
في اكثر من بلد تحديدا برلين وباريس دائما
على حذر لاسباب اقتصاديه ديموغرافيه رايي
الشخصي انه لن يتم قبول تركيا طالما موجود
اردوغان في السلطه
اتفاقيه موقعه منذ اخر قرن 19 بين السويد
وبين روسيا تضمن شكل بقر الحياد السود على
دخولها في حروب مع روسيا انضمام الى حلف
الناتو هو عكس ما كانت تريده روسيا في
حربها وهذا يظهر فشلا كبيرا ايضا في الحرب
الروسيه روسيا ترفض الى حد بعيد انضمام اي
دول جديده خاص المحازيه لها على الحدود
هناك على الاقل حدود تصل الى 1400 كيلو
متر بين فنلندا وبين روسيا وبالتالي ان
تتخلى هذه الدول عن حيادها طب نتكلم عن
تحول نوعي كبير جدا يعيد رسم العلاقه مع
روسيا وامريكا ومعها اوروبا الغربيه
بالقول ان كل ما كانت تدعيه موسكو من ان
حربها استباقيه بسبب احتمالات توسع الناتو
ها هو يتوسع عبر فنلندا والسويد علاقات
الروسيه التركيه على مدار 10 سنوات تشهد
بان هناك امكانيه تجاوز اي خلافات راينا
ذلك في اكثر من مره تدخل العسكري التركي
في شمال سوريا ووجود الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا ان انقره وموسكو تتواجهان
في ليبيا تواجهتها في ارمينيا اذربيجان في
اكثر من ملف ايضا العلاقه متوتره تراهن
روسيا على انه من الصعب قبول تركيا داخل
اوروبيه قويه بين طرفين تتفهم بشكل او اخر
موقف تركيا من الضمام السويد الى حلف
الناتو ليست ابدا بصدد التخلي عن كل
الامكانيات تفاهم مع انقره هي تحتاجها ان
بسبب العقوبات الاقتصاديه او بسبب بحر
الاسود والموقع الاستراتيجي التركي على
مدخل هذا البحر ضعف السوري الذي هو مشترك
بينهما علاقه ستستمر بين الطرفين لكن بظني
ان الحسابات التركيه الان صارت اكثر نحو
ضروره الابقاء على علاقه مع موسكو لكن
تمتين العلاقه اكثر من جديد مع الغرب ومع
واشنطن
دخول العالم في مرحله جديده جدا تقوم على
تقسيم العالم
من جهه وما دونهم من جهه اخرى تتحدث عن
اكبر تحالف دفاعي في التاريخ منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه على الاقل بنتكلم على 30
دوله وتم
ضمة والامر مخيف للغايه وامكانيه ان يتم
يعني اتساع مساحه
كوريا الجنوبيه
نعم سبب عجز موسكو عن الانتصار في حربها
الاوكرانيه ومرور وقت طويل على هذه الحرب
واحتمالات ان تستمر لفترات اطول يرى
الاتراك انها مع الوقت ستضعف الموقف
الروسي وربما تتيح للصين ان تكون حليفا
استراتيجيا بديلا او موازيا عاده تعريف
هيكل الامن الدفاعي داخل اوروبا والذي حدث
على خلفيه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
عندما راينا وشاهدنا تحول نوعي فيما يتعلق
بمزينات الدفاع لدى الدول الاوروبيه نسبه
الاوروبيين هناك تحدي مزدوج اولا
الاستمرار في الانخراط ضمن هذا التحالف
تطوير قدره اوروبيه راضعه من دون الاحتياج
الدائم الى واشنطن لكي لا تبدو العواصم
الاوروبيه ملحقه
بالبيت الابيض او بالقرار الامريكي ان
تكون اوروبا مستقله امنيا ولو ان الامر
صعب ويتطلب وقتا طويلا